Ein Moment.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Elgazis mein Name.
Heute bin ich die zuständige Erste auf dieser Station
und führe gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnese gespricht.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Klar, Sie kennen sich ja bestimmt aus.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen,
brauche ich einfach Informationen über Ihre persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Albert Lang.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen noch stabieren?
Ja.
Albert, A, L, B, E, R, T
und Lang, L, A, N, G, E.
Albert Lange.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Vornamen?
Albert ist der Vornamen.
Ah, ich meine Albert Lange.
Okay.
Danke schön. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 48.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie zu sein?
Nein, wie ist so 80 kg?
80 kg. Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausärztin?
Frau Dr. Schröder.
Schröder. Okay.
Danke, Herr Lange.
Was führt Sie zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, wissen Sie, mir geht es seit Monaten schlecht und immer schlechter.
Und ich bin so, ja, ich kenne mich selber nicht wieder.
Ich bin müde und schläfrig, mir ist immer kalt.
Ich habe zugenommen und bin ständig verstopft.
Und ja, ich könnte ständig einschlafen
und habe das Gefühl, ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr die Leistung erbringen wie früher.
Und das macht mich, ja, das macht mich ganz unruhig.
Und deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich muss mal unbedingt mich vorstellen,
wenn ich mich beim Arzt.
Seit wann genau haben Sie diese Bechweite?
Ach, also, dass mir das so richtig aufgefallen ist,
so ungefähr seit einem Vierteljahr.
Ein Vierteljahr.
Waren Sie schon mal beim Hausarzt oder beim Anders?
Ja, der Hausarzt hat gesagt, ich soll mich doch mal in der Klinik vorstellen, ja.
Okay.
Sie sind müdig und schläfrig und es ihnen kalt.
Ja.
Und wie viel Kilo haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe immer so 76 gewogen und jetzt wirklich ab 80.
Also, vier Kilo habe ich zugenommen.
Im Vierteljahr, oder?
Ja, ungefähr so in der Zeit, ja.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ach, der ist eigentlich gut.
Ja, ich kann gut essen.
Und das.
Okay. Und Sie haben auch Verstoffung.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Ja, also manchmal klappt das nur zweimal in der Woche.
Und ja, manchmal nehme ich dann auch so laksulose Serobe.
Damit das überhaupt in die Gänge kommt.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhl?
Wie sieht Ihr Stuhl auch?
Na ja.
Haben Sie etwas Bemerk, Blut oder Schleim?
Blut habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Nein, nein, das ist aber eben sehr fest.
Alles, ne?
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen?
Irgendwann eine Körperteil an.
Nein, richtig Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Können Sie sich gut konstantieren?
Nee, eben gar nicht.
Also ich habe Schwierigkeiten selbst, also mein Arbeitsalltag
über die Runden zu bringen, ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie?
Ja, ich bin Angestellter im Verwaltungsbereich in der Forstverwaltung.
Und ja, das
ist natürlich viele Zahlen, die wir verarbeiten müssen und anträge
und Statistiken bearbeiten.
Und manchmal könnte ich darüber einschlafen.
So kaputt bin ich.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie mehr als gewöhnlich?
Ich würde gerne den ganzen Tag schlafen, aber
als ob man in so eine Art Winterschlaf verfällt,
fühle ich mich im Augenblick.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Veränderungen in Ihrer Haut oder Nagel bemerkt?
Ja, also tatsächlich, aber ich, das habe ich jetzt aufs Alter geschoben,
dass mir die Haare ausgefallen sind.
Das ist ja bei Männern so, dass die eben irgendwann ausgehen, ja.
Und das ist aber wirklich, ja, da haben Sie recht die Fingernägel,
die brechen mir zur Zeit ab, die verrückt, ja.
Die Nägel brechen einfacher.
Was?
Ja, also dieses Material ist nicht mehr so elastisch, ne?
Okay.
Ich habe das aufs Alter geschoben, ja.
Darf ich fragen, haben Sie
Schwerigkeinbein, äh, Geschlechtsverkehr?
Ja, eigentlich nicht, nein.
Bekommen Sie Ihre Periode?
Ich bin ein Mann.
Ah, ich bin ein Mann.
Okay.
Und, äh,
haben Sie Probleme beim Lungen oder Herzschlafen,
Herzrasen oder Atemnot?
Na ja, sowas.
Also, Atemnot habe ich nur insofern,
ich habe so ein bisschen Polypen in der Nase.
Und, äh, da hat man
vor Jahren mal festgestellt,
dass ich, dass ich so eine, so eine Schlafabdül hat.
Und dann habe ich eine Zeit lang auch mal so eine Maske getragen.
Aber damit bin ich überhaupt nicht zurechtgekommen.
Und dann habe ich die wieder weggetan.
Und, und jetzt trage ich die nicht mehr.
Aber, äh, ja, seit der habe ich natürlich auch wieder die Probleme,
dass ich manchmal, äh, eben wegen Schnarchens aufwache
oder dass ich eben nicht so gut Luft bekomme in der Nacht.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese
Atemnot beim Schlafen?
Ach, das habe ich bestimmt schon acht Jahre.
Ja, da hat man das mal festgestellt.
Und dann habe ich mal für ein Jahr lang probiert,
mit dieser komischen Maske das zu machen.
Das ging aber irgendwie gar nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei,
was soll das sein?
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie, ja leider, unter, äh,
Fieber, Fütterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein, also zu warm ist mir eher nicht, mir ist eher immer kalt.
Okay, immer kalt.
Also jetzt, so bei solchen Wetter muss ich immer mit der Wärmflasche
schlafen gehen, sonst kann ich gar nicht einschlafen.
Okay.
Danke, Herr Lange.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankung gemessen.
Haben Sie eine dauerhafte Krankheit,
Bluthochdruck, Blutschkalkrankheit,
außer diese Schlafabneuen?
Nee, sowas nicht.
Das Einzige, was ich noch hab,
ich hab also am Kopf so eine,
so eine Hautveränderung, so ein Exem.
Äh, und da muss ich halt manchmal,
äh, äh, ja, also den Mund,
muss ich so ein, so ein Spezial-Champo benutzen,
um die Haare zu waschen, damit, äh,
die Haut da nicht so gereizt ist, ne?
Sind ihr Haut trocken?
Ja, da ist die Haut so schuppig und trocken, genau.
Okay.
Äh, haben Sie Schwellung im Hals bemerkt?
Schwellung im Hals? Nein, die hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig oder Weibedarf?
Also das Einzige, was ich nehme,
das ist eben dieser, dieser Lacholose-Seru-Weibedarf, ne?
Dann nehm ich das Haar-Champon und, ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen hab,
ich hab häufiger mal so, so, so Kopfschmerzen,
dann nehm ich Aspirin.
Aspirin. Okay.
Wie oft nehmen Sie Aspirin?
Ne, ja, vielleicht so dreimal im Monat oder so.
Also wenn ich mal wirklich merke,
dass ich starke Kopfschmerzen hab, ja.
Okay.
Äh, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nee, ich bin mein Kind, ne, nie operiert worden.
Okay.
Äh, sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Sie meinen gegen Corona? Ja, da bin ich geimpft.
Okay.
Und natürlich, ja, manchmal sind wir ja auch im Außenbereich tätig
und müssen mal so, äh, so in die, in die Wälder direkt gehen
und da sind wir dann vielleicht so bei, bei Baumfällarbeiten dabei.
Insofern haben wir immer eine Tätagnoss-Impfung.
Tätagnosch.
Da sorgt unser Betriebsarzt schon dafür.
Ja, okay, das, das, das tut mir leid.
Äh, waren Sie im Nächste seit, im Ausland?
Nein, ich hab immer nur Rolapier in Deutschland gemacht.
Wir waren immer Wandern und so.
Aber ja, hab ich jetzt gar keine Lust dazu.
Okay.
Äh, jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit.
Rauchen Sie?
Oh, ich bin seit neun Jahren rauchig nicht mehr.
Früher, äh, haben Sie...
Früher hab ich ja, 20 Jahre lang hab ich, hab ich ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht, ja.
Das war nicht so leicht aufzugeben, aber ich bin froh, dass Sie es geschafft haben.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen mit dem Rauchen.
Mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören.
Äh, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also Alkohol würde ich das nicht nennen.
Ich trink ein bis zwei Bier am Abend, ja.
Täglich.
Ja, so gut wie ja.
Okay.
Am Wochenende auch mal ein bisschen mehr, oder wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, ja.
Aber normalerweise eigentlich regelmäßig ein Bier abends oder zwei.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie, haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Bedrohen? Nein, nein, nein, damit habe ich nichts zu tun.
Okay.
Herr Lange, äh, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Äh, meine Mutter ist vor zwei Monaten erst gestorben.
Das war ja sehr überraschend, ja.
Ja, es ist nicht so leicht.
Woran ist sie gestorben?
Der hat, also man weiß das nicht so genau, das Herz ist stehen geblieben mit einem,
also wahrscheinlich hatte sie ein bisschen Herzprobleme im Vorfeld.
Und äh, ja, also mit einem war es, war es vorbei, ohne große Vorankündigungen.
Ja, okay.
Und Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater lebt noch.
Äh, ist er ja gesund?
Ja, der hat irgendwie so ein Problem mit den, mit den Nebennieren.
Da funktioniert irgendwas nicht so gut und das macht ihm so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten.
Da muss er irgendwelche Medikamente nehmen regelmäßig.
Äh, er lebt nicht hier in der Nähe, deswegen kriege ich das nicht so genau,
denn er hat das nur mal erzählt, ja.
Okay.
Äh, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ah, leider nicht.
Der, äh, da hat man jetzt vor einem Jahr den Daumenkrebs festgestellt.
Und der ist behandelt worden und scheint ihm jetzt aber eigentlich gut zu gehen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Äh, haben Sie Kinder?
Äh, ein Kind haben wir.
Ein Kind?
Ist Ihr Kind gesund?
Ja, also klar, klar, das ist ja noch jung, 13 Jahre alt, ja.
Das freut mich sehr.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienzustand?
Mein Familienstand, ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet und haben Sie ein Sohn oder eine Tochter?
Eine Tochter.
Eine Tochter, okay.
Und Sie leben zusammen?
Wir leben die ganze Familie zusammen, ja.
Okay, und Sie sind ein Angestellter?
Ich bin Angestellter in der Forstverwaltung, ja.
Ja, Forst.
Äh, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ähm, manchmal mit dem Vorgesetzten,
aber also nicht, nicht wirklich schlimmen Stress, nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Äh, haben Sie Lust, mit Ihren Freunden zu treffen oder auszugehen?
Zur Zeit überhaupt nicht.
Das ist eben das, was mir so zu schaffen macht, ja.
Dass ich am liebsten mich vergriechen würde und,
ja, ich, am liebsten würde ich morgens schon gar nicht losgehen zur Arbeit.
Und bei der Arbeit bin ich eben so, so schlapp.
Und wenn ich dann endlich zu Hause bin, mache ich eigentlich auch nichts mehr, na.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme zu Hause oder in der Arbeit?
Nein, jetzt habe ich natürlich Probleme, weil meine Frau sagt,
jetzt wolltest du doch die Küche aufräumen, du wolltest doch im Keller was machen.
Ja, und ich dachte, ich habe aber keine Lust.
Und ich, ja, ich komme eben nicht in die Gänge, ne.
Ja, Sie haben auch Kraftverlust, vielleicht.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich hab das Gefühl, ich könnte es im Augenblick einfach nicht, ja.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Lange, ich habe eine weitere Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, möchte natürlich wissen, was dahinter steckt, warum ich so, so schlapp bin
und, ja, was man dagegen tun kann vor allen Dingen.
Das ist so für etwas klar zu sagen.
Zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und werde ich belut abnehmen
und einfach Untersuchungen führen.
Dann bespreche ich Ihren Fall mit meinem Oberarzt.
Jetzt komme ich zurück und teile Ihnen mit, was zu tun ist.
Okay, das klingt doch noch einem guten Plan.
Ja, ich habe mich auch sehr geholfen.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Kommt gar nichts mehr.
Ja, Sie waren schnell und Sie waren sehr komplett, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ich denke, eine gute Annemnis ist.
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie Schüchternmehode Schülükschörungen?
Ich kann es nicht vergessen.
Ach, Schluck?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Entschuldigung.
Schluckstörung ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut gelblich oder blesse geworden sind?
Gelblich nicht.
Was ich gemerkt habe, dass die Haut eher so trocken ist,
ist, dass die Haut so trocken ist.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Könnten wir als erstes gescheitert anfangen?
Würden Sie schon, Frau Dr. Iwas?
Ja.
Guten Abend Frau Oberstein.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn Sie den gesehen haben, dann können Sie das sehen.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn Sie den gesehen haben.
Es geht um Herr Albert Lange.
Er ist 48 Jahre alt, 1,75 m groß und 80 kg schwer.
Er sterte sich bei uns seit ca. 3 Monaten.
Er hat eine bestehende Müdigkeit, Schleffigkeit und Kartegefühle.
Er hat eine Kartegefühle und eine Ausfassung vor.
Er berichtete, dass er sich unruhig fühle.
Er hat eine Ausfassung vor.
bis auf Gewichtsunahme von 4 kg in 3 Monaten.
Und in Somia wegen dieser Beschwerden und Schlafabne wurde unerfällig.
Er klagt über Haarausfall und Nagelbrüche.
Brüchen genägelnd?
Ja, Brüchen negelnd.
Und alles vor Erkrankungen habe er seit 8 Jahren Schlagabnögen.
Aber er kann die Maske, ich glaube, dass er wahrscheinlich Zip-up nicht mehr benutzen.
Warum nicht?
Er kann das nicht, er fühlt sich nicht gut, er möchte nicht.
Er toleriert die einfach nicht?
Ja, er toleriert die einfach nicht.
Und er habe auch trockene Haut, besonders auf der Kopf, verwendet.
Er hat eine Speziale Haar-Famphu.
Er hat eine Formitis glactose und Aspirin bei Bedarf.
Er wurde nie operiert.
Er war vollständig.
Die Reise an Amnesien sei unaufgällig.
Er sei nicht rauch, aber früher habe er für 20 Jahre
ein Pakkungsigaret im Protakt geraucht.
Das heißt 20 Jahre.
Er trinkt 1-2 Jahre abends.
Am Wochenende ist manchmal mehr.
Er hat eine Konsum-Rolle.
Seit der Familie Anamnesien sei die Mutter wahrscheinlich ein Herzkrankheiten gestorben.
Der Vater hatte keine Krankheiten, aber der Patient kenne die Krankheiten nicht.
Er hatte auch einen Bruder,
um die Bruder zu erheben.
Sehr gut.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Er ist eine gesundere Tochter und manchmal hat er Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ja, alles.
Ich gehe von einem Pferdach auf Hypothrose aus.
Als differenzialer Diagnose komme ich mit der Anämiedepression.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ich werde den Patienten den Körper untersuchen.
Worauf haben Sie dabei?
Herz- und Lunge-Untersuchungen.
Halb- und Palpationen sind wichtig.
Ich gucke dann den ganzen Körper.
Wo achten Sie das speziell?
Ich beobachte die Haut.
Die Haare, die Nagell, die Nägel.
Ob er Blässchen hat wegen Anämie.
Oder eine vergrößerte Troide.
Worauf schauen Sie noch?
Schauen Sie nach den Füßen?
Beinfüßen.
Ob es Schwellungen gibt?
Ja, vielleicht.
Was testen Sie noch im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ein differenzialer Alkohol-Bild und Erzündung.
Was untersuchen Sie noch mit?
Wenn Sie an Ihre erste Verdachtediagnose denken?
Ich habe eine Hyperteroide.
Jetzt fällt es mir nicht rein.
Vermutlich hat er ja ein bisschen reduzierte Reflexe.
Reflexe, neurologisch.
Ein paar neuropische Tests.
Jetzt kommen wir zum Labor.
Was machen Sie da?
Wir haben einen neuen Teil, der Blutbild-Enschonung-Parameter.
Freie T3- und T4- und Antikörper-Antitroglymin.
Antitroglymin.
Ja, auch Vitamin B12-Werte.
Was machen Sie dann noch für eine Untersuchung?
Ich fühle auch unter Ultraschalen.
Genau.
Ja, Treut-Ultraschalen.
Was wäre dann die nächste Stufe, wenn man da einen auffälligen Befund hat im Rahmen der Sonographie und auch im Rahmen des Labors, was wären dann die nächsten Schritte?
Treuzintigraphie vielleicht?
Ja, genau.
Wenn wir ein Blut, wo Knoten vollfinden, können wir bei einer anderen Funktion durchführen.
Gut.
Ja.
Und ja, was wäre in Falle Ihrer Verdachtsdiagnose die angemessene Therapie?
Hormon-Ersatztherapie, ja, Altruxie.
Und wahrscheinlich geht es ihm dann zügig besser.
Und ja, Kontrolle und Untersuchung.
Ja.
Gut.
Wissen Sie, wie auf Deutsch die Vergrößerung der Schildrüse heißt?
Strom oder Knopf?
Kopf, der Sturmer oder Kopf, genau.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, super, kommt alles.
Ja, das kann Ihnen Taselle im Schwarzwald begegnen, ne?
Da könnte das sein, dass da jemand mit einem Sturmer kommt.
Ja, gut.
Ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über den Herrn Lange und was bei Ihren Untersuchungen
rausgekommen ist.
Wunderbar, sehr gut.
Danke schön.
Ja, also ich denke mal, das war sehr komplett.
Eine Sache ist mir jetzt im Rahmen unseres Gesprächs aufgefallen, hat,
meine ich auch, hat niemand gefragt, bestehende Allergien haben Sie nicht gefragt?
Ja, ich kreffte jetzt von Ihnen.
Ja, aber ich habe es irgendwie auch im Vorfeld nicht bemerkt und hat auch sonst
keiner bemerkt, das ist ja auch irgendwie nicht das Thema,
das irgendwie ist, liegt es bei diesem Patienten so sehr auf der Hand,
worum es geht.
Und da insofern ist man eigentlich ja nicht so richtig motiviert,
da noch so viele Randfragen mitzustellen.
Ja, Sie haben sehr komplett gefragt, also mit diesem kleinen winzigen Ding,
die nicht, die Allergien nicht abgefragt.
Was ich nicht so eine glückliche Formulierung finde zu sagen,
die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Eigentlich ist die vegetative, also seine Symptome,
spielt ja eigentlich rein in die vegetative Anamnese.
Er hat eine Obstipation, ihm ist kalt und naja,
gut, die Schlafproblematik hat natürlich die Schlafabmüh als Ursache.
Ja, aber dann kann man, finde ich eigentlich nicht gut sagen,
und er hat Gewicht zugenommen.
Ja, das sind zwar Punkte, die praktisch neben Erscheinungen sind der Erkrankung,
aber es ist ja keine unauffällige vegetative Anamnese,
sondern der würde ich sagen, im Hinblick auf die Diagnose
sind folgende Punkte der vegetativen Anamnese interessant.
Ja, und dann kann man das sagen, der hat Gewicht zugenommen,
der ist verstopft und ja, dem ist kalt und ja, naja, gut.
Aber sonst waren sie, waren sie sehr vollständig,
sowohl in der Befragung als auch in dem, was sie geschildert haben.
Haben Sie eine Idee, wie diese neben ihren Insuffizienz heißt?
Ne, neben ihren Insuffizienz, Adrenalinz, nein.
Das ist Morbus Edison, das haben die Prüfer hier nämlich
gemenerweise mal nachgefragt, deswegen sage ich das nur.
Und sie waren dann auch sehr komplett in der körperlichen,
in den Untersuchungsvorgehen und natürlich auch in der Therapie.
Es ist alles gekommen leerbuchmäßig, was man sich so wünschen kann.
Also, deshalb kann man das glaube ich nicht viel machen.
Ja, gut, wann dürfen Sie Ihre Prüfung machen?
Neunzehnte, Elfte, ich habe noch zwei Tage.
Das ist sehr bald, ja, wunderbar.
Gut, ja, aber das läuft bestimmt sehr, sehr gut.
Hoffen wir mal, dass Sie eine hübsche Hypothoriasen kriegen, ja.
Ich habe in Freiburg sehr selten, aber ja, ich schleife.
Was ist Spezialität für Freiburg?
Normalerweise, wir haben fast 70 Palle,
aber besonders in den nächsten Prüfungen gibt es Gastrointestinal-Sepfalen.
Kardiale Sachen wahrscheinlich auch immer, oder?
Wie bitte?
Kardiale Fälle, so Herzinfarkt oder?
Ja, ja, Kardialfälle und psychiatrische auch, Depressionen und Panikatate.
Echt?
Ja.
Ui, ja, na gut, ja, spannend.
Also, jedenfalls alles Gute für Sie, das ist bestimmt unproblematisch.
Ja, vielen Dank.